how's it going guys wanted to talk a
little bit about
rendering systems that you can use for
your own
custom games and engines
and this is something i've been looking
at for a while now and i was trying to
make my own
game based off of well using one of
these
so i'll just go to that real quick
also testing out recording here at a
higher resolution it was pretty laggy
so yeah i was trying to develop
underdark tactics and
i got a pretty good idea for the game
and how it's all going to flow
but getting the rendering set up well i
had previously used
some custom opengl i wasn't really happy
with the direction it was going and the
limitations i was running into
so i wanted something i could do some
cross-platform rendering
and uh well i'll just tell you
i'm basically just going to go over what
i've learned so far so
first of all i did a little research and
kind of settled upon bgfx as
a system for doing all the rendering
stuff
um it was pretty easy to get some basic
stuff going
but i started hitting
some roadblocks and it hasn't been all
that fun the goal of building underdark
tactics was basically to have fun the
main goal
is to have fun coding and it has not
been fun working with bgfx
but from what i'm reading none of these
are particularly easy
and fun and we'll get to some other ones
here shortly
so i probably got about as far as the
meshing and
stinson uh
started messing with textures a little
bit and then i just kind of got to a
point where i was like
i i don't feel like this is very
intuitive
so this is probably the most popular one
out there
uh there are some i see a lot of
complaints about the code quality and i
do understand that
uh one of the main problems seems to be
well i'll try to explain this this is
really my personal opinion so i don't
want to act like this is
uh well i don't know i'll just
explain what the roadblock i ran into
with the code
okay so there's these three libraries
they all go together i was able to get
them
up and going pretty good let me just
launch it actually
so i was able to get
all three of those and with sub modules
oh this is really laggy trying to record
a 1080 with this computer is just not
happening
so i've got them all in his sub modules
i've got bgfx bm hbx
and i've got cmake that does everything
you can set custom commands to build
but i just build them with make and i
have it basically yell at you
if you don't have them so when you go to
build the main app
this is going to be a bit of a rambly
wild video about code
and rendering and and stuff so hope
you're you're up for all that
so basically if it doesn't see that the
library is built
it's going to yell at you and say hey
this was not built for release or debug
or whatever you're trying
other than that there's a bunch of
different libraries in here
some of my custom made actually all of
them have custom made
the ones that are not custom made are
brought in from these external modules
well this main loop one is mine but glfw
i'm using for windowing and input
i've got these three libraries i've got
asm for the model loading
that's all really fine but trying to get
all this
rendering set up and set up in a way
that like i can
kind of modularly make levels with
has not been super user friendly and i
don't know if it's the fault of
my lack of digging into the library far
enough
or something else but i've been stuck
for like a week
and i don't like being stuck for a week
it's starting to feel bad starting to
feel real bad so i got to make a change
so basically i i was like trying to i
was just trying to get a texture
loaded which sounds really easy but it
wasn't really easy
i couldn't really find any clear support
on how to do it
like if
if you look at if you just google search
how to load a texture with vgfx
you basically get someone you know the
creator of the thing
saying oh just look and look here
it's it's done right here in the utils
there's an image load
but then if you look at image load well
i was able to build this comment as a
library
but then it has a problem of it's
already looped in with its own main
so i can't use my own main and trying to
extract that out was just taking me
forever and i was running into more
nonsense
and then nothing's all in just one file
like
if you want to use this bgfx utils
there's a whole bunch of files in here
you need there's a whole bunch of files
and entry that you have to
figure out how to extract and that entry
has a main and it's like a whole
windowing system
that's actually probably set up pretty
nice but i've already kind of committed
the glfw
so i don't want to use that but the way
he has
like the the thing to bring in images
written
forces you to use that and it just
causes an error and i couldn't figure it
out
quickly uh so i was just getting annoyed
basically
is what was happening and i'm willing to
bet i could figure it out eventually but
like how many more days do i want to
waste
digging through his code and it's like
it's some bs code if you ask me i like
obviously the creator of this is a way
better the coder than me don't get me
wrong
but for me trying to go through it is
like
physically making me a little angry at
this point
because uh i guess if i did a live
stream of it and you just like saw
the pain you'd probably understand but i
literally just spent four hours straight
messing with this and i basically feel
like i got nowhere
and it's it's driving me nuts it's and i
i don't consider
myself a bad coder like i can walk i can
read any code and walk through all of it
and tell you exactly what it does
but the problem i'm running into is just
that
like you go look at one thing and you're
just going down the rabbit hole it's
like okay now you got to go here
and it's got one thing from this file
and one thing from this file and one
thing from this
file and one thing from another library
over here
and it's like i just i just want this
simple little piece in one file i don't
want it all over the place
and it's like you can't just build you
can't just use it as it is
because it's attached to some main thing
already
oh god it's driving me nuts to have to
dig through all these files and try to
abstract like
20 different things just to load a
texture i just want to load a texture so
i figured i'd just use stb image instead
and that's going to be way simpler but i
was like i don't want to have to include
more stuff
i literally already have the code in
here i'm just duplicating code if i
bring in more stuff
so like just a search of
let's see bgfx
load images
there's like this right here
and it's basically all the stuff i was
already going through
this guy asked how to load a png says
well there's a utility right here and
it's in the bgf utils it's already the
nonsense that i've been going to that
has frustrated me
so much and this is just one thing it's
there's been more stuff too
and there's another guy that says hey
you can use either
and he says hey the same mr cove does it
i looked the image to code some
but at that point i was like oh man
i'm already deep in the rabbit hole
anyway so that's bgfx
bgfx has it's
it's clearly got a lot of potential it's
it's clearly super cool a lot of people
have already made a lot of good games
with it
but i feel like i want to explore more
before committing because
like i said i've been stuck for like a
week and i'm not i'm not happy with it
i'm actually very very
very annoyed but i still think it's like
an awesome project
and i would like to get into it more
later so another one i was looking at
was diligent
diligent actually looks pretty similar
he actually has cmake so yeah bgfx is
all make files there's no cmake
which is fine i i'm good with make files
so that was fine for me
but if you're not so familiar with them
you might be really confused and get
stuck
so this one it uses cmake so it's a
little easier to
to set up and it has a better
walk-throughs of tutorials
so i thought that maybe i'd try out
diligent i just remove
all the bgfx stuff and try out diligent
but i haven't done that yet
so diligent looks really nice the code
is very modern
and pretty clean looking so if you just
like go through the samples there's
plenty of stuff
that you know has some pretty clean code
and examples already set up which is
always nice
really it's going to come down to the
shaders there's some decent sample
shaders
i'm not a big fan of writing shaders to
be honest it's it's
something that i would prefer someone
else do so
maybe that's part of my problem it
probably is
so diligence another really nice
cross-platform
rendering option this one seems to have
better
samples and tutorials in my opinion but
it is not is it's not as old it's not as
well tested and all of that so that's
like
i guess that's the downfall
or not the downfall but
the downside i guess you would say is
it's just not as heavily tested
as bgfx as vgfx has been around forever
and i suppose i didn't actually really
want to close that so i'll leave it open
now i was doing some searching and i
just started typing in vgfx and i
noticed that
bgfx vs magnum was a reddit thread
so let's let's take a look at that and
see what we can learn
so someone asked basically what's a good
3d rendering engine for use with c plus
plus s pvr and good lighting system
and of course there's ogre3d over 3d is
really old i've never actually used over
3d and i always wanted to
so i was considering maybe i should try
that out
i don't know but i guess i just need to
have like
one week of trying out all of these and
then just pick one to go with
uh i think that's probably what i'm
going to do next week
let's just try i try to out all of these
so this is like
overview this is kind of like the intro
video it's probably gonna be a little
series of just trying out these
different rendering systems
i don't know i'm really i'm really
winging this and it's
probably gonna be interesting if you
like code so
subscribe if you like code because
that's pretty much what this channel is
going to be about
code and computer hardware and stuff
all right so someone suggested
if you wanted to look like unreal why
not use unreal
and yeah that makes sense using a game
engine unreal
unity godot
it makes a lot of sense so that's
another thing i might explore too
i've i've toured around a lot of game
engines but ultimately i kind of want to
make my own
you know i have a series already about
this ancient archer engine that i've
been building i kind of put that on hold
while i started exploring rendering
engines because i was building my own
rendering stuff on there
and it was a little overwhelming but it
was actually kind of fun
so i've just been thinking about you
know
pushing that off to to one of these
libraries
all right well some other rendering
stuff came up euro 3d
isn't a render it's a full-blown engine
but
apparently euro 3d is another one to
look at
atomic is just a rename of euro 3d so
there's there's some mentions of stuff
here
of course bgfx is mentioned
i think the thing for bgfx is it's not
very new
friendly you have to be like super good
and you have to have like a couple
good weeks to dedicate to getting
started with is
what i feel like i think that's i kind
of
you know i thought i would have it in a
day or two but that just wasn't the case
like sure i could get
basic stuff in a day or two but like
fully understanding and the capabilities
and how to use everything
that got a little bit more complicated
it got pretty rough
pretty fast all right so some other
people are mentioning engines
and let's see
bgfx or over 3d most others are full
game engines
i guess there's diligent too so we're
looking at bgfx over 3d or diligent it's
basically what i'm seeing at this point
of course well there's magnum too no
one's really mentioning magnum
too much so let's look at this thread
about
uh
bgfx versus magnum there's this live
hunt link i think i got it open already
no maybe not all right we'll click on it
and this is just like a little library
comparison
so bgfx is growing but the activity is
declining a tiny bit
and magnum the popularity is declining
looks like it
oh what is this just uh
i don't know how they go off this rating
exactly i don't know how they read it
but it looks like it's a little more
stable it looks like it actually has
cycle releases on magnum
so and it looks like it has a little bit
higher code quality according to
luminify so as you can see
bgfx has the lowest code quality rating
l1
and i get that now you know when i was
looking at it for the first
forever i thought you know maybe this
guy's just really good and just doing
more advanced things
than i'm aware of and that's why it
seems so complicated but
now after kind of seeing the code
quality review it makes sense
stuff is just nested really oddly in my
opinion
on vgfx and i found it hard to follow
through the code and what
all was going on also it would probably
help have had a better editor because
visual studio code you know how usually
in your editor you can just go
look for the definition of stuff and
other files
well visual studio code you cannot
figure out this library
like you just have to go manually hunt
through files basically or run a grep
search or something
to find where the functions actually are
sometimes
because visual studio code can't figure
it out it doesn't know where things are
automatically even when they're
referenced and stuff
so i found that to be a bit frustrating
uh okay so magnum i haven't looked at
magnum apparently it's another pretty
popular one and i think it's one we need
to go
check out so let me just open up a tab
here github.com
i hope this video is watchable i'm
seeing a lot of
lag i'm trying to make sure it gets into
1080. let's search for
magnum and it should be one of the top
ones
there we go yep
mosera magnum okay
take a sub model mod module some tool
chains
documentation project home page
supported platforms linux windows mac
android web
okay that's cool looks like it's
currently just opengl
opengles and webgl so it's all just
opengl
which is not really what i want i want
to have the option to do directx 11
and vulcan but
you know i'm already kind of messing
with opengl on my own so
uh you know that deters me a little bit
but i'm
not against giving it a try still maybe
it's like really intuitive and really
nice
i don't know yet let's take a look at
are there any screenshots of anything
built i always like seeing those
maybe the docs
yeah there's a lot of stuff here
so there's a lot of docs i guess that's
a good thing
let's see let's take a look at some
source code here he does use cmake
that's nice
i love when they're using cmake
good bit of stuff here
i don't know let's just take it take a
gander at what the code
looks like i'm seeing a lot of if deaths
name spaces templates okay and really
really long lines of code
all right well that's not necessarily
bad but
it's not my personal taste i find those
to be a little hard to decipher when
first looking at the at them so
uh this isn't too bad just an overloaded
out operator
what is this it's just a file fallback
i don't know it's hard to hard to really
get
a gauge of this here from just looking
at a little bit
what a pitcher trying to make the world
a better place
you eating humans okay i shouldn't it's
just very vampire looking
very dark picture that's not what that's
about probably a pretty
pretty good coder all right
well i don't i'm not really trying to
i'm just really
interested in the libraries here that's
just a very uh profound picture
pretty cool though all right so let's
look at some other ones
let's just real quick i'm just going to
look at my little ancient archery thing
it's kind of old at this point
master branch yeah it all runs it's all
like a scripted thing but it's not
it's not super
hey it needs a lot of work i haven't
worked on it and
apparently it says two months i'm pretty
sure it's been longer than that
i don't know i used to have some
pictures somewhere maybe they're on the
tags
yeah they probably have the tags
let's look at
this box of world one
can i go to the code base no i can't all
right i'm not forgetting about that
so earl 3d is another i guess this is an
engine
so if i'm going to use an engine i'm
probably going to use unreal or godot
but i guess it's worth looking at
greatly inspired by over 3d and horde 3
what's horde 3d
that i'm not familiar with
it's an open source 3d rendering edge
okay so here's another one i didn't even
know about
so they've got a github repo
ford 3d
so their little blur of their features
modern cross platform
shader based architecture requires open
gl
resource management uber shader based
unified pain system unified low level
animation
content pipeline
looks like it uses cmake
okay so and well we got here
some build stuff okay
in order to build the samples you need
glfw so he's using glfw for the
windowing
on his samples at least all right so
there's another one that's pretty
interesting i'm going to start this to
keep in mind here i guess i'll start all
of these i look at
we'll start magnum
cool all right
horde 3d so that's that's cool
i didn't know about that
and let's look at ogre3d i haven't
looked it over in a while
remember looking at this like years ago
before i even
really understood what was going on
i know there's a lot of really good
coders out there i'm i'm getting there
i'm still actually relatively new like
sometimes i'll see people that are like
just
just amazingly good at coding and i'm
thinking geez
they're so far ahead of me but then i
realize or i hear something like
oh i started coding when i was eight i'm
like oh no wonder
geez you've been coding for like 40
years i've been coding for like
five years i guess you know what i've
been coding for like 40 years i'll
probably be
crazy amazing too so i did it makes me
it puts into perspective when you see
someone who's really good at coding
they probably just coded a lot and
practiced a lot
well let's look at i don't know i really
do want to try out
ogre at some point so i'll probably just
make a list
and go through all these maybe make some
kind of long-form videos of trying out
all of these they might be live cast
might cut out cut them a little bit but
let me know what you think
down below leave a comment of what you
would like to see if you want to see me
test out some of these rendering engines
and just kind of go through it so you
can get a feel for it
and just have something to kind of watch
and uh
get some ideas okay
the ogre cave all right let's sorry i've
already got starred so i've been here
before but it's been a while
so it builds on everything basically
that's cool they do use cmake
nice and they do have some samples here
they've got multi-layered terrain
skeletal animations bump mapping
integrated shadows
volume rendering okay cool
and using i am gui here particle effects
very nice oh it was used for torchlight
too i played torchlight too that's
awesome i don't think i've played any
others but torchlight 2 is really fun
it looked pretty good
all right well over is looking pretty
good
so yeah i guess that's it let's see what
else do i have open here i have uh
oh this is just learn opengl so i'm
going to narrow it down to just these
last pages
bgfx diligent
ochre
this is more like a game engine this
euro thing
cross platform yeah okay so we're gonna
skip that
i didn't see oh here's magnum okay
there's magnum
we'll close that and then we've also got
horde 3d
which has its own repo we'll leave the
repo up in there
that's my stuff okay so it looks like
we've narrowed it down to one two three
four five rendering engines
five different rendering engines not
game engines
just cross platform rendering stuff that
you can
use as a library basically and plug in
all right well let me know what you guys
think i'm going to probably do
but it'll take me a while but i'll do
five videos i'll go through all these
this one was sort of about bgfx so i
might skip that
unless i get anything really new
and uh i'll see you guys in the next
video peace out
keep coding and uh don't forget to drop
a like
share this video share the channel
subscribe
all that stuff i'm uh always trying to
ramp things up
and uh peace out